لا زالت توصف الان من قبل الكثير من فئات
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ليس فقط الفلسطيني
والعربي بانها الاكثر تطرفا وتدين وتشددا
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الكنيست يمنح ثقه لحكومه
نتنياه التي يكونوا صفوا بالاكثر تطرفا في
اسرائيل وفي خطتها تعزيز الاستيطان بالضفه
والجولان وتجديد السيطره على القدس
نتنياهو قال ان المهمه الاولى لحكمته يا
احباط مساعي ايران لتطوير سلاح النووي في
حين تظهر اسرائيليون امام الكنيست
بالتزامني مع جلسه منح الثقه للحكومه
مقاطعه الاوكرانيه عده تتعرض لهجوم
الروسيه واسع حيث سقطت عشرات الصواريخ
عليها فيما اعلنت موسكو اعتراض اهداف
مجهوله في منطقه انجلش قرب القاعده الجويه
الروسيه وفي بيلاروسيا قالت السلطات الى
صاروخا من نظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
سقط داخل اراضيها موجه جديده من اعمال
العنف القبلي في دارفور غربي السودان
اعلنت مقتل ثمانيه واصابه اخرين وحذرت من
جديده في وقت توجه فيه وفد من مجلس
السياده السوداني برئاسه حميتي الى
المنطقه للوقوف على الاحداث
تراجعت تجاره العالميه بنحو تريليون دولار
هذا العام بسبب تداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وذلك بحسب دراسه حديثه لمعهد بروجل
للدراسات الدراسات ذكرت ان اسعار الطاقه
ارتفعت بنحوي 100% واسعار السلعه غير
المتعلقه بالطاقه 8% الى اللقاء